Let's take a bird's eye view of the process we just went through in transforming
this equation. Since we were aiming for having a perfect square at the end, on
the right-hand side of the equation involving x and a constant, we knew that the
initial constant we started out with couldn't be right, since right now, we
can't factor x squared minus 8 x plus 15 to be in this form. That means, we need
a different constant attached to the two terms with x in them. So, the first
step was to get rid of the initial constant we had so that we could have a
different constant, on the end of the x squared minus 8x. You've figured out the
constant that belonged at the end of those two terms was 16. When we add 16 to
this, we get the perfect square of a binomial. This process is called completing
the square, since the constant that we add on over here ends up giving us a
squared expression as our answer. Now, we don't' technically have to move the 15
away from the right-hand side to do this. But I think that it makes dealing with
these two terms on their own a little bit easier, since we don't have anything
else to look at on the right side. So, completing a square is a crucial part of
transforming equations of parabolas from standard form, into the form where we
can see the vertex. Now that we understand how to complete this square and the
importance of that technique in transforming equations from one form to another,
I'd like you to rewrite the equation y equals x squared plus 5x plus 6 in the
form that we've been talking about. Now, if your numbers get a little bit messy
in here, don't worry. That doesn't mean you're doing the problem wrong, that
often happens in math. So, just go with it and then at the end, you can always
check your answer by plugging in points to the equation that you start with and
the equation that you end with to make sure that they're the same.